it's no secret that Japanese animation
can go to some pretty weird places but
just how strange does it really get from
experimental short films to psychedelic
rollercoasters here's a look at some of
the most bizarre Japanese anime ever
made paprika based on the 1993 novel of
the same name 2006 is paprika centers
around dr. Atsuko Chiba a research
psychologist who begins testing a
groundbreaking new psychotherapy tool
that allows users to enter people's
subconscious minds to get glimpses at
their dreams and rewire their
personalities when the tech is hijacked
things go haywire we're talking building
leaping skin peeling body morphing crazy
in a surreal setting filled with
larger-than-life creatures half-human
hybrids and walking refrigerators it's a
cautionary tale about meddling with the
minds of mankind told through a deeply
bizarre nightmarish lens that erases the
line between real life and pretend
critics have called paprika and
eye-opening mind trip not meant to be
understood a film that rarely makes
sense for all it's unsettling elements
cat soup cross anthropomorphic kittens
and a creepy sort of coming-of-age tale
and you've got cat soup inspired by the
works of manga artist Neku Jiro and
directed by Tatsu Osato this bite-sized
anime from 2001 follows the relationship
between two tiny intelligent cats Yoko
who is extremely ill and yatta who's
rendered clinically deceased after a
tragic accident not willing to give up
on his dying sister nyata
embarks on an engrossing grotesque
voyage to rescue nacos soul from a
Buddha like figure the pair swap bodies
split Souls shove their hands inside a
giant pig and take part in a Noah's Ark
scenario in their spirit searching
journey think of it like Hello Kitty
mixed with Salvador Dali which is to say
that it's very very strange interstella
4/5 if the full name of this anime alone
didn't tip you off that this is
something else what goes down in
interstellar 45 the story of the secret
star system will boggle your brain
directed by kazuhiro takaguchi known for
his work on Dragonball this anime can
best be billed as a Daft Punk Fantasia
it has no dialogue
just retro inspired visuals done by Toei
animation set to an electro Punk
soundtrack while interstella 4/5 is
essentially a music video accompaniment
to Daft Punk's 2001
album discovery it actually tells the
pretty strange story of a ragtag band of
alien musicians who get abducted and
shipped off to earth to play for legions
of adoring fans but there's a catch
skin altering procedures species
exploitation and a rogue pilot who will
go to the end of the universe to save
the band's female member await you in
interstellar 4-5 the anime that plays
out like a techno driven fever dream you
won't ever forget Gil Tokyo fish attack
the title of 2012's Tokyo fish attack
pretty much explains it all fish rise
from the sea on shiny metal legs to
terrorize the city of Tokyo as the film
runs on waves of increasingly dangerous
sea creatures come crashing to the shore
prepare for incredibly cheesy romance
scenes spooky circus people power-hungry
mad scientist's mutants with bathroom
based powers and a squid that may make
you never want to eat seafood again Gil
Tokyo fish attack which is based on a
horror manga series has its fair share
of gory moments but the violence doesn't
seem too serious when you remember that
the bad guys are walking fish mind game
the weird work of writer and director
masaaki yuasa mind game is the story of
Nishi a young man who dreams of one day
becoming a comic book artist and winning
the heart of his childhood crush after
the to have a brush with the Japanese
mafia me she gets trapped in a spiritual
limbo filled to the top with
mind-bending existential themes and
unusual animation mind game source
siruni she's wild journey back to the
living world on a road marked with giant
whales caricatured villains and neon car
chases which is as cool as it is bizarre
dead leaves this 2004 sci-fi anime tells
the tale of two unlikely rebels retro
and Pandy who are shipped off to prison
after committing an insane string of
crimes while locked up the pair meets
some out there characters and have their
patients put to the test the story only
gets weirder as the plot unwinds without
spoiling the madcap twist retro and
panties post prison adventures see them
encountering an oversized demon
caterpillar and a mutant baby crash
landing on to a dystopian earth and
possibly breaking the space-time
continuum
how's that for bizarre tech ankh in
Crete the title of tech ankh in Crete
translates from Japanese to English as
reinforced concrete and that concept
holds true to the central vision and
underlying moral tale of this anime an
adaptation of a manga series this film
surrounds penniless
orphan brothers kuroh and Shiro in
sights and sounds that dizzy and dazzle
the viewer the pair robbed their way
through treasure town without much
trouble until the Yakuza entered the
scene upon the arrival of the notorious
Japanese gang check on kin Creek
devolves into a disturbing hypnotic
string of scenes that flip-flop between
true crimes in the trippy world of
Shiro's mind as with a few other films
here Tek on kin Creed will move you but
not before shaking you to your core with
it's unsettling strangeness angels egg
released in 1985 angels egg tells the
story of a young girl who lives alone in
a lair in an abandoned city where she
serves as the sole protector of an
enormous egg that apparently holds great
value after a mysterious boy joins her
the two witnessed several mystical
happenings involving orbs goddesses and
angels and chat briefly about philosophy
and theology though the film clocks in
at around 80 minutes not much of its
runtime is comprised of actual dialogue
instead the avant-garde anime leans on
wispy plot and heavy abnormal visuals
doubling down in the final act to reveal
a cryptic half resolution so you know
don't forget the popcorn thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]